hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a horror drama film called the
bad seed
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
at the beginning of the movie we see a
nine-year-old girl named emma grossman
watching a cat drowning in a fountain
through her room's window she closes the
blinds and goes on with her morning
routine showing no remorse to the
drowning cat emma lives with her widowed
father named david grossman
she is an excellent student and a
well-mannered kid
however she seems to have no human
emotions
that day at breakfast emma tells him of
her ambition to win a citizenship award
at school as the two talk emma's aunt
angela comes in
she informs david of a new babysitter
she has found for emma it turns out that
emma's previous babysitter suffered an
unfortunate accident as they talk emma
points out the dead cat in the fountain
david brings the cat out but emma seems
void of any emotions about its death
that day at school a wasp scares the
children as they study as the students
retreat in fear emma bravely takes a
glass and captures the wasp to let it
fly outside the window
meanwhile david interviews a babysitter
named chloe he likes her portfolio of
work so he hires her chloe seems to be
interested in david
back at school emma's classmate katie is
playing when she bumps into emma who
helps her get up their teacher watches
the events unfold it looks as if emma is
trying to be compassionate to win the
citizenship award that night emma
practices smiling in front of the mirror
the following day is the award day david
dresses up emma and drives her to school
all the parents and students are seated
in the audience when the teacher
announces that milo has won the
citizenship award emma is beyond
disappointed when david talks to emma
about milo's win she says that she was
the one who deserved it and begins
insulting milo she apologizes when david
looks at her disapprovingly
sometime later when no one is watching
emma takes milo to show him a cliff
nearby
when milo suggests returning emma walks
towards him and the screen goes blank
later when milo's parents ask her if she
has seen him she lies and says she
hasn't seen him since the bonfire
suddenly two girls come running from
somewhere screaming for help
all the parents run to see milo has
fallen off the cliff and drowned in the
ocean
his father carries his washed up body
and tries giving him cpr but milo is
dead
the following morning at breakfast david
asks emma how she feels but she
completely ignores the fact her friend
died the day before
later the new babysitter chloe comes to
the house that night david isn't home
emma finds chloe and david's room
stealing some of david's medicines
later as they watch movies emma
confronts her about the drugs she
promises to not tell david if chloe does
what she wants emma then orders her to
get her an ice cream chloe calls the
little girl a but does what she
says
the following day is milo's memorial
after the ceremony everyone is crying
except for emma david talks to milo's
parents and finds out that the metal is
missing they assume that it sank in the
ocean just then emma begins to cry too
it is as if she is pretending to be sad
in front of milo's parents
when they come back home david is
worried about emma's behavior
when he folds emma's laundry that day we
see that milo's medal is hidden under
emma's mattress david looks through the
pictures of the award day and finds
several pictures of emma glaring at milo
he suspects that his death has to do
something with emma
later that day emma's teacher mrs ellis
and a police officer visit david to talk
about milo's death
mrs ellis claims that someone had seen
emma with milo in the cliff before his
death
emma listens to their conversation from
the door
she fakes falling on a base and hurting
herself to stop the adults from talking
seeing that emma is hurt mrs ellis and
the officer leave
while taking care of emma's wound david
asks her if she was with milo in the
cliff but emma denies when he reveals
that mrs ellis said she was emma gets
agitated and yells that mrs ellis hates
her
the following day chloe goes to their
side house where david is working
she asks him if she can smoke there but
david denies saying that the place has
too many inflammable liquids
right after chloe takes emma to the
street to play with her scooter while
they are at it the two see mrs ellis's
car in front of milo's home
she is talking to milo's mother chloe
says that they are building a case
against emma she knows that emma did
something to milo however the little
girl acts like she doesn't know what
chloe is talking about
when they come back home they continue
the conversation
chloe tells emma that if they find out
what happened to milo they will sit emma
in an electric chair
this scares emma but she still doesn't
admit to doing anything
later that day chloe is looking for emma
around the house when we notice the wasp
nest that had been in the ceiling of the
outhouse is gone
then we see mrs ellis drive away from
milo's home
as she drives a wasp distracts her which
almost causes an accident she continues
to drive when the camera pans to the
back seat the wasp's nest lies there
emma has put the nest in the car to try
and kill her teacher
back at home chloe finds milo's medal
under emma's mattress
she hangs it in a lamp in david's
dresser so that emma can be caught david
is in his bathroom when emma comes to
his room and sees the medal
she gets it off the lamp and hides it
behind her but david notices he brings
her back to her room and confronts her
about it emma lies and makes up a story
about milo giving the medal to her as
they played david goes for a drive to
take mind off this when he sees a car
crashed on the side of the road
he also calls angela and asks her to
find emma therapist
david begins to get nightmares about
emma and milo
the following day emma confronts chloe
about her putting the medal there
she is furious just then david comes
downstairs and asks emma to come with
him he takes her to milo's home to
return the medal back to his mom
she is confused but thankful that she
brought it back
she then informs them about mrs ellis's
death she had had a car accident because
of the wasps david is surprised emma
begins to cry claiming that mrs ellis
was her favorite teacher
however on their way home emma seems to
have forgotten about mrs ellis's death
and talks about baking cookies with
chloe david is unsettled by emma's
behavior
later as david is working in the
outhouse he notices that the wasps nest
is gone he suspects his daughter for mrs
ellis's death
the following days emma's first
appointment with her therapist dr march
she and emma have a long chat after the
session the doctor tells david that emma
is like any other normal child emma even
fooled a psychiatrist
when the two come back home david comes
across chloe sunbathing in her sports
bra
he asks her to go to emma as chloe and
emma talk she tells the little girl that
david was looking at her seductively
earlier
she also adds that she can be her
stepmother
furious emma screams at her to stay away
from her dad
that night emma asks david if he likes
chloe david is confused
she also reveals about chloe wanting to
be her stepmother
however david is late for a date so he
leaves without giving her much of an
explanation
sometime later chloe hears a noise as
she is watching tv
she goes looking for emma but cannot
find her anywhere
she looks at the outhouse through the
window and sees a shadow there
she goes out to look for her
when she gets into the outhouse the door
closes
she tries to open it but it seems to be
locked from outside just then a fire
starts spreading on the floor chloe sees
emma watch her through the window
she tries to hit her but the fire
indulges her killing her eventually
david comes home to the firefighters and
paramedics in his house they tell him
about chloe's death emma has been taken
to an official's home he finally gets to
emma and hugs her
that night david comes to emma's room he
sits down in front of her and lovingly
asks her if she hurt milo he assures her
that he will do anything he can to help
her but she has to tell him the truth
emma finally admits that she pushed milo
off the cliff she makes an excuse by
saying that he was going to report her
for taking his medal she then casually
says that she won't do it again david is
horrified
he then asks her about mrs levia emma's
previous babysitter she reveals that she
pushed her down the stairs because mrs
leviah grabbed her hand
she then claims that leviah should have
been more careful
emma gets progressively aggressive as
she talks
when asked about what she did to chloe
she yells at david and blames chloe for
trying to be her stepmother david is
anxious he cannot believe that his
little daughter can commit such a
horrible crime
the following morning the town sheriff
calls david and says he wants to meet
emma however david makes an excuse about
her being sick
he then takes her to their lake house
far away
their housekeeper welcomes them
later that day the sheriff calls david
again to inform him that the fire was
set deliberately by someone but they
don't know who
seeing that his daughter might get
caught he is anxious david has a gun
with him at the house
he looks at it now and then thinking if
he can put it to use to solve the
situation
the following day as david is asleep
emma comes into his room and kisses him
she closes all the windows and turns all
the gas stoves on an attempt to kill her
father emma then goes by the lake and
stays there
just then david wakes up and smells the
gas filling up the house
he quickly opens the windows and turns
the stoves off
he sees emma outside at the lake and
realizes that she has tried to kill him
he walks up to her and asks her why she
did that emma replies that if something
happened to him she gets to go live with
her aunt angela who actually likes her
david holds her hand and calmly takes
her into the house
then we see david crush his medicines
later he brings emma a cup of hot
chocolate the two drink the hot
chocolate together and david tucks her
to sleep when he comes back to his room
he calls angela and tells her everything
about emma's wrongdoings but she doesn't
believe him he apologizes to angela and
vaguely tells her that he has no other
options it turns out that david had
added drugs in emma's hot chocolate in
order to overdose her so that she
doesn't kill more people but he doesn't
tell angela this that night when he is
asleep emma enters his room
she holds a gun in his hand and points
it at himself
she fires but misses sending the bullet
to the pillow beside david the noise
wakes him up and he asks her how is she
still alive
emma replies that she had switched her
hot chocolate with david's
seeing that she was about to kill him
david leaps to snatch the gun from her
hand emma quickly takes his phone and
calls 9-1-1
she then runs away to the bathroom as
david follows her with the intention to
kill her emma tells the 9-1-1 operator
that her father is trying to kill her
david breaks open the bathroom door and
points his gun at emma just then the
housekeeper appears behind him with his
rifle
when david is about to kill emma he
shoots him instead emma watches as her
father falls down to the ground and dies
the police arrive to
cut to the following morning and angela
arrives at the scene
she tells emma that her dad was probably
sick the movie ends as we see emma hug
angela and smirk with a cold predatory
look on her face
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching